d'accord, quelle est l'histoire de certains gars qui
sont entrés par effraction dans les maisons des gens en
assassinant les parents en épargnant les
filles restent dans la maison avec
les parents des corps J'aime écrire des
histoires d'incidents dans un pays fantôme est votre
livre le plus personnel jusqu'à présent vos ventes sont à
travers le  toit ils t'adorent et ils
t'aiment
je ne sais pas le talent inquiet vient de
ce que tu fais
ta capacité à créer tes propres mondes
je suppose que la question est pourquoi écrire ce
livre mais pour éviter de devenir fou dans
la maison personne n'est ici non pourquoi  est-il
ici je sais ce que tu attends de ta
soeur est-
ce que tu comprends maintenant mal ce que
tu m'as fait
sauf ce qui s'est passé W jour arrête de
t'enfuir